this sort of a mixed story about
pandemics you know Ebola and Zika MERS
and SARS Lassa fever swine flu bird flu
there's been more more animal viruses
jumping from animals to humans in the
last thirty years than we have records
of before and that's worrisome but much
more worrisome than that is that but
institutions that normally keep us safe
are sort of a wall in the Ebola outbreak
Obama sent 3,500 American soldiers to
West Africa we spent billions of dollars
because w-h-o failed in its job to
protect us because it took six months to
correctly identify what the disease was
that was killing people in West Africa
so whu-oh is going to have a new
director general in May and I think it's
going to go through a period of
self-examination and it's offline and I
think this presidency as far as
pandemics is offline you know you're not
gonna see public health let alone
pandemic preparedness at the top of the
priority list for this White House and
they fired the head of CDC and they're
cutting asunder for Disease Control
Center for Disease Control or centers
and Trump is cutting the budget for
Public Health and pandemic preparedness
there's a new Secretary General of the
UN who just began in the first of
January really good guy Portuguese guy
really good but he's just getting
started so if you look at those agencies
that normally keep us safe the federal
government
w-h-o the UN CDC they're all off line
we've got a great head of the World Bank
as a dr. Jim Kim he'll be working really
hard but by and large we have to have a
safety net to protect us to stop
pandemics to end the threat of pandemics
April 7th is
HealthDay it is also the 100th
anniversary of the great influence of
the Spanish Influenza in the 1917 to
1918 pandemic one of my grandparents
died in that one of George's
grandparents died and then I wonder how
many other people know that in your you
know in your genealogy some of your
relatives died from that because
somewhere because 25 million and a
hundred million people died in that one
year period and if you put that to
today's numbers you're talking about 75
to 300 million if we had a pandemic
one-tenth of that 100th of that it would
bring humanity to its knees there
wouldn't be an airplane in the sky for
six months who's gonna get on a cargo
boat with 300 people that whose
epidemiological status you don't know
when there's no vaccine and no antiviral
I want us to stop the risk of pandemics
we know almost every well we know every
step to take we know how to do it
there will inevitably be outbreaks
they'll be viruses jumping from animals
to humans outbreaks are inevitable but
pandemics are optional we don't have to
have them if we have the same public
will to end them that we had to
eradicate smallpox and that's what I'm
hoping that we can pull off next
[Music]